[Music]
we have somebody in what I call the
failing New York Times that it's talking
about he's part of the resistance within
the Trump administration this person
this is what we have to deal with and
you know the dishonest meeting but it's
really a disgrace so when you tell me
about some anonymous source within the
administration probably who's failing
and probably here for all the wrong
reasons now and the New York Times is
failing
if the failing New York Times has an
anonymous editorial can you believe it
anonymous meaning gutless a gutless
editorial we're doing a great job well
the president reacting to the New York
Times op-ed from an anonymous what they
call a senior administration trump
administration official where it is
titled I am part of the resistance
inside the Trump administration I work
for the president with like-minded
colleagues I have vowed to thwart parts
of his agenda and his worst inclinations
saying that he's impetuous adversarial
petty and ineffective Sarah Sanders
saying this is pathetic and reckless
selfish and quote this coward should do
the right thing and resign just in the
past few minutes senator bob Corker from
tennessee who is not running for
reelection said this this is what all of
us have understood to be the situation
from day one I understand this is the
case that's why I think all of us
encourage the good people around the
president to stay I thank general mattis
whenever I see him let's bring in our
panel byron york chief political
correspondent of the Washington Examiner
Amy started associate editor at
RealClearPolitics and Washington Post
columnist Mark teason okay mark
obviously this is anonymous
this comes however after the Woodward
book and the president is reacting not
just once twice he just tweeted out
treason question mark
well treason might be a little bit
strong but he's right to be mad look the
deep state just confessed the deep state
that turns out is not the permanent
bureaucracy it's not Obama holdovers
it's apparently people who donald trump
appointed to senior positions inside the
government we don't know who this person
is but many of the story that what did
the ED day activity he describes tracks
with what's in Bob Woodward's book if he
and with named people to it I mean in
Bob Woodward's book
Koen it apparently admits to having
taken decision memos off the President's
desk and bragged that he didn't even
notice they were missing there's it
there's a story and they're about how
after good Asad gassed his own people
trunk called up Madison said he wanted a
plan to eliminate Assad which is a
legitimate military targets and Madison
reportedly put down the phone and said
we're not doing that who elected these
people commander-in-chief when you have
unelected represent appointees
undermining and refusing to carry out
lawful orders by the elected
commander-in-chief
that's not defending democracy that's
undermining democracy president push
back on that particular reference about
Syria and Assad today saying that that
is just not true here he was in the Oval
Office with the Emir of Kuwait he'll
stay right there his we're very we're
very happy with him we're having a lot
of victories we're having victories that
people don't even know about and he's
highly respected all over the world and
I did appreciate his day because he
didn't have to write that statement but
I did appreciate and I appreciated the
statement of John Kelly and I
appreciated the statement of many others
it's somebody you know every week I seem
to have a book coming out some good
stuff in all fairness I get some good
ways too but I like to take him on when
they come out that's a piece of fiction
that was not it but here is the
president on the Woodward book just gave
me I think because the book is you know
total piece of fiction and he was
totally not even misquote it he never
made the statement he came out with the
statement said honestly you know I've
heard over the years that general mattis
is an intellect and when I read his
statement I asked him whether or not
this was true he said not only is it not
true I'd like to write a statement I
said thank you very much it's very nice
all right I mean we're about this well
it was so interesting the Senate
Majority Leader's reaction to you which
was that he refused to respond in any
way pretended he had known nothing about
it until you set it up in the intro and
he twice said he wanted to talk about
the accomplishments of the Congress not
even the Republican government he later
heralded the accomplishments of a
unified republican government only 20
years of the last 100 don't want to
squander this opportunity but twice he
was talking about
the accomplishments of that Congress
after comments like Senator corkers yes
he's retiring but he has said these
things for a long time it's a day care
someone needs to be in control you know
in charge of the toddler or whatever he
said a year ago everything in Bob
Woodward's book rings true of things
that we've already heard in the past
saying with this op-ed that what is the
response to this going forward two
people resign from this administration
does this person resign everyone on the
internet is calling them a coward is the
best thing to do to keep staying on the
inside the response from Republicans it
really it's just another kind of drama
unless the response changes well on the
op-ed this really is extraordinary
perhaps unprecedented but I think what's
striking about it is how small this is
the the author concedes in the op-ed
pretty high up that many of the
administration's policies have already
made America safer and more prosperous
mentions deregulation tax reform a more
robust military and then the complaints
are about the president is not a real
philosophical conservative he really
doesn't believe in free minds free
markets free people he changes his minds
at meetings his instincts
are not all that great but this is a
rather small-minded criticism of a
person they really don't like in
meetings but they concede that on the
big things that we elect presidents for
this president's made a lot of progress
the president talks a lot about a
witch-hunt
and the Moller investigation but there
may be a witch-hunt on going to find out
who this person is and who was talking
to Bob Woodward do you think inside this
administration well there certainly
shouldn't be a hunt to find out who this
person is because look there's a
difference between being in the
administration with the goal you know we
here keep hearing the phrase adults in
the room these are not adults who are
doing this who are subverting democracy
there when you go into the
administration and they're good people
in there who say mr. president you
really shouldn't pull out of NAFTA mr.
president you really shouldn't put these
tariffs down that's one thing you go in
and if the president makes a decision
that you really really fundamentally
opposed then you resign but it's
entirely another thing to go into the
administration pretending the serve of
the President
who was elected by the American people
and subvert his decisions nobody elected
this guy nobody elected Gary Cohen
nobody left at any of these people and
so their job is to follow the code
lawful orders of the commander-in-chief
or resign and if they're not Patriots
New York Times cause the he but